[Music]
she has sexy side but also being
vulnerable and open with up with
audience demi lovato and Kalani sizzle
onstage and pack on some heavy PDA yep
let's rewind and see that one more time
it all went down Monday in Newark New
Jersey during the last us stop on Demi's
tell me you love me tour Kalani's the
opening act in both singers left quite
an impression during their final show
together
kailani wrote on Instagram that Demi's
dancers encouraged her to surprise Demi
on stage during lonely a super sexy
number they kissed and things got steamy
[Applause]
after the sexy show both singers opened
up on social media
Kalani gushed anyone would be stupid not
to jump at the chance to hop on that
damn moving bed and grab your face while
Demi wrote what an incredible fun sexy
crazy night that I'll never forget
et spoke with Demi in February we
actually only meant for like the first
couple songs to be sexy we wanted to
showcase all aspects of my self as an
artist Demi
kailani ladies you keep doing you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]